MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to [INAUDIBLE],,
special relativity.
So moving from
special relativity
to general relativity,
we relax the requirement
that reference
frames can only have
a constant relative
velocity to each other.
So we are looking
at what happens now
if you have accelerating
reference frame,
and the first example is that
of rotational time dilation.
So I mentioned you have a
device which has two clocks.
And so the first block
sends it ticks up
in terms of light beams, beams
with some specific frequency.
So there is a
transmission going on,
and there is a receiver
on the other side.
And the clock, the
upper clock, u clock,
submits the same things.
They both have the
same frequency,
let's say 10 pulses per tick.
We also assume now
that we don't have
to consider special relativity
effects, yes, so the velocity
of the thing is very small.
OK so relativistic
effects are small.
But when I now
accelerate this device,
there is an interesting effect.
The lower clock will receive
more than 10 pulses per tick,
so it is perceived as running
slow from the upper clock,
right.
So the lower clock is expecting
10 ticks, but it's seeing 12,
so you think that your
clock is running slow.
Similarly you can
discuss the upper clock,
which because it's
accelerating upwards,
it only receives
8 pulses per tick.
So it's expecting 10, so
it's perceived to be faster.
Now, this acceleration
as in this example,
as I've discussed previously,
is equivalent to being
in a gravitational field.
So we have a time
dilation effect on us.
We already discussed
the consequence
in the discussion
of GPS systems.
Here is a summary of this
plot, and just showing you
the effect of changing
gravitational fields
as a function of the distance
of the center of the Earth.
And you see that the rotational
speed-up, 0 on the Earth's
surface, becomes rather
large the further away
you get from Earth,
while if you consider
that the object, a a satellite,
in an orbital motion, the speed
of this object is kind of
compensating partially.
But there is this net effect,
as we discussed earlier,
on the GPS system.